This right here is a GoPro Hero 5,
today we're gonna put this in the center of a car tire and spin it really really fast and see what kind of crazy images we can get,
how crazy you might be asking?
let me show you...
Here it is so this is a GoPro that's spinning really really quickly
Crazy and a certain point it starts like syncing up with itself like almost to a point that like the spinning rate
matches the rolling shutter rate
So you can actually end up seems kind of like how when you're going on a freeway and tires look like they're going backwards
It's just syncing up with the refresh rate of your eyeballs
This is a raw image from the camera not edited after the fact. This is exactly how the camera captured it
there's a pig?!
he really comes over and like, "wuz dis?"
the reason why you're getting this really crazy weird artifact here
Is this effect known as rolling shutter
Destin from smarter every day has a fantastic video
Explaining what this artifact is and how sensors work
But basically you have a video and it's say 30 frames per second well one of those frames is also recorded over the course of time
from the top to the bottom a single frame from a video is actually
Recorded from the top and then like a millisecond goes by it record a little bit more another millisecond goes by of course a little bit more
and then over a few milliseconds it records the entire image
That is so fast that for most of the time it appears like a solid static image
But if you have something that's spinning really really quickly it like
Rotates through that and it creates these really weird artifacts as you can see in Destin's video what I wanted to do today was figure
out how we can recreate this sort of super fast spinning and
See if we can get any sort of artifacts similar to what we're seeing in this video so in the past we have done some
Pretty crazy rigs the GoPro in a cannon
the GoPro in a sword video, but today
I specifically want to do something
Jankier and quicker probably just gonna put this in a case and gaff tape it to your car tire
(Nick): Isn't that gonna be a problem when we started going really fast?
(Wren): I hope not I mean maybe do you have hubcaps for wheels there's a difference?
(Nick): I don't know.
(Wren): if you have nice wheels you don't need hubcaps.
(Nick): I guess we'll go see
I wanna do the back tire, oh that's the big one is the a380!
(Nick): Billy you like aeroplanes?
I think I'm gonna try to shoot 2.7
K at 30 frames per second for it to be perfectly centered for the the lens it needs to mount right there
Okay, you ready no return after this sticky stuff sister
Peel it off and then
Wait how do how do I do that?
Wow I'm a tape of master I built an entire
Two-story fort out of cardboard using just ran. I've been taping since day one dude
I was taping since before you were born you can't be bad if the sticky part fails
Will this tape be enough to hold it there?
Go prone attire oh you suck O'Brien era that's not coming off that is excellent
You're not relying on the stickiness
You're relying on the strength of the tape yo we can talk about tape all day or we can take it to the streets
You can't go wash my hands real quick, No
Is this on tape
This guy over here Harley is kind of worried, but the other part of me is like no my tape Jonas Wallace
And once you've done a full rotation you have officially gone 80 point 7 inches
I'm trekking with 7.6 miles an hour
That's exactly 100 rpm the closest I can do is just keep it right in between five and ten which is basically seven oh
What's up, man
Should we bring street meat guy to do these experiments with this?
Dude, hang a grill down our street wearing a robe
girl some food
She we experiment with Streamy guy
We put a GoPro on the tire
I noticed that that was like a little thing that was given out over there fifteen miles an hour
All right, and the GoPro is still there. You're so good. We haven't lost the GoPro yet
See how fast you can go just get as much speed as you can fly off the bridge
So at 60 miles an hour that was
785 revolutions per minute so we got up to 700 85 RPM on the gopro well we want to hit a thousand first
Let's review the footage we can take I could fall asleep. I can live here great in this position
I have to go to the bathroom
We're about to watch some footage that could trigger epileptic people into a seizure so or anyone
You want to mount our I can't I can't look at it
See that is like ready okay now on the bridge, this is when you're picking up the most feet
We're forming it into almost one plane we need to go faster, though
we don't know how fast we have to go for it to sync up because if you don't actually know what the
88 miles an hour well we can go out on the highway and try to go as fast as we can
I didn't see what happens
This is Phase two
We did a first test which actually worked out really well
Once we got up to like 60 miles an hour something strange happened
And we want to see if we can recreate that that means we got to go a little bit faster
We're gonna go the speed limit
I don't know what that speed is I mean here in LA you can go like 85 miles an hour without
Being worried about getting pulled over. That's just an Los Angeles fact. We're gonna go right after the speed limit and no faster
Just
Wait
It is rolling what speed we had
From my face
Okay
Now try to hold at 70
Just like Cruz at 70 we got our data Nick so you you held it going 80 for a bit
And then you managed to get it up to 90 for a little while like
65 what I'm hoping is that we actually reach a level of harmonization with the framerate and the spinning speed
firetruck
I'm hoping that we'll get some stabilization in the camera itself oh
Yeah
Sent you one. Yeah. He did I was no longer jealous many other thing
It only makes you sick when your eyes can somewhat track it. Okay, if you're going slow enough that faster speed you can't track it
Yeah, Oh
Start to go the other way again, but yeah you see how crazy that curve is that's because of the rolling shutter
Whoa whoa, okay? We're getting up speed
Something's happening something's happening
So 70 was what is this look at that it captured part of the ground in the one frame at the top
But then by the time we got down to halfway through the frame. It was now recording it at the bottom
Whoa dude you're seeing the truck upside down and right-side up in the same image
So weird and cool, it's
Okay, oh okay, now. It's cool
Huh, okay
916 rpm that's the speed at which you need to spin the GoPro for the rolling shutter to sync up with the
Horizon I was hoping that we'd get it perfectly like every frame is like say every frame the ground is here
That's the case you'd have to be going a hundred and forty miles an hour, so it's like every other frame is the ground
Perfectly because it's like it syncs up
Right here, you can see the spinning of the horizon this start to slow down
And then it's stuck right here, but we're still getting the flashes back and forth let's play through it at normal speed
This is normal speed
It's a little too jarring here at normal speed but playing in at fast forwarded speed because it matches up
When you're playing a fast forward speed is dropping that one frame so in theory should get pretty smooth
And it does it does get smooth, so you don't have to go 140 miles an hour
You just have to double the speed of the footage so yeah, this is this is way cool right 2x speed than 1x speed
That is so sweet, dude yes